le monde de la culture en colère
artistes et professionnels du spectacle
manifesteront après demain un peu
partout en france pour réclamer un plan
de relance de l'activité
les cinémas eux sont fixés il devrait
rouvrir le 15 décembre un soulagement
tâter teintée d'amertume pour les salles
en régie municipale
elles ont tout simplement été exclus des
aides pour le secteur
exemple à des cartes et lamotte beuvron
avec hélène chapelet depuis 15 ans
georges est le projectionniste du cinéma
de la mode devront de nombreuses
affiches sont passés entre ses mains
mais celles ci ont une valeur un peu
particulière celle de la reprise de
l'activité
bientôt l'unique salle 244 sièges va
retrouver une partie de ses habitués il
était temps car depuis le début de
l'année quatre mille cinq cents entrées
seulement ont été comptabilisés
loin de 2019 et de ses quatorze mille
places vendues les pertes sont estimées
à 42000 euros
et c'est la mairie qui va devoir combler
le manque à gagner car depuis 2018 la
salle et son exploitation sont gérés par
la municipalité
si 50 millions d'euros dead ont été
prévus par l'état pour le secteur
cinématographique
aucun des 386 cinémas municipaux n'y ont
accès
l'état pense que les municipalités
peuvent
voilà un budget ou des recettes autre
que celle du que cette du cinéma donc
voilà ils ont fait le choix de soutenir
que le privé qui ne vit effectivement
que de que de ça mais il faut savoir que
voilà c'est un vrai choix politique
d'avoir un cinéma municipal dans sa
ville que ça un vrai coup à descartes
également c'est la mairie qui exploite
le cinéma en moyenne dix mille entrées
sont réalisés dont l'unique salle pas de
quoi dégager des bénéfices
et encore moins cette année pour
équilibrer les comptes il va falloir
réinjecter 80000 euros une aide de
l'état aurait donc été la bienvenue
si on veut que la culture reste
accessible un maximum de gens il faut
donner les moyens ce que la culture
reste accessible les salles municipales
font partie de ces équipements
après moi je
je ne sais pas quels seront les les
volontés de ceux qui nous dirigent mais
leur décision sera lourde de
conséquences
que ce soit des cartes ou à lamotte
beuvron le maintien d'un cinéma
s'inscrit dans une vraie politique
d'accès à la culture en milieu rural
sont ces salles de proximité il faudrait
faire plus de route pour se faire une
toile ou tout simplement y renoncer